voilà un peu moins star mais star quand
même alors huit stars on a du mal à
imaginer l'ambiance sur le tournage et
dans les coulisses
est-ce qu'elle n'est pas la clé pas de
concurrence par exemple entre vous
catherine deneuve
non enfin c'était pas consulté avant
mais franchement non non non non c'est
vrai que ça donne pas beaucoup prise à
ce genre de nous a posé la question
beaucoup au début puis je crois que très
vite tout le monde s'est rendu compte
que c'était pas vraiment l'actualité du
film parce que on était un groupe et je
crois que c'est vrai qu'il y avait plus
et une atmosphère de pensionnat cp oui
mais franchement honnêtement oui je le
redis les égaux des stars d'abord on
n'est pas destinée des actrices ont été
vite vous serrez vite ça devient une
somme c'est plus je sais pas c'était
c'était vraiment différent quand même où
fanny ardant ont dit vous étiez assez
réticente vous dites j'aime pas trop les
colonies de filles vous ai dit saluant
son spot wi et puis je me suis trompé
parce que oui
mam est prise en compte et ça à 101
malargé dit les femmes entre elles écrit
que c'est pas très naturel mais le
cinéma c'est très concret alors on se
retrouve avec une scène plus une scène
plus une scène et de ses 8
elle se transformait en une plus une
piscine et tout moi j'ai un très bon
souvenir comme du champagne
est-ce que c'est flatteur quand même
dans un film comme ça on a l'impression
un peu d'appartenir finalement là quoi
j'allais dire presque une élite
on a choisi on a choisi les stars n'en
rêviez
après robin n'a pas été choisi parce
qu'on était des stars parce que d'abord
c'est un amour un peu quand mais non
mais aussi parce que si vous voulez de
françois ozon voulais faire un film où
il
il avait des personnages et enfin il
avait il connaissait les personnages il
détruit des actrices qui correspondent à
ses personnages
on pourrait refaire la distribution
peut-être pas ici ce soir mais la
semaine prochaine si vous voulez on
pourrait très bien imaginer d'autres
actrices dans nos rôles
il y aurait au moins deux ou trois
distributions possible je pense pour ce
film non c'est pas du tout simplement il
a été comme c'est quelqu'un
d'intelligent et de très très malin
c'est vrai que je crois qu'il sait il a
su très bien se servir de ce que nous
avions déjà fait au cinéma avant dans
d'autres films pas lutter conte parce
que c'est vrai que les actrices connues
on se dit toujours mais il ya un espèce
de flottement comme ça par rapport aux
autres films qu'on a fait avant dont il
s'est servi de ça il ya des références
et même côté pas de référence oms il
s'est servi je veux dire de nos
notoriété de la crise lui dit quand même
il ya eu un peu de tension et dit je me
suis cantonné dans un devoir de
neutralité pour pas avoir l'air de
privilégier l'une par rapport à l'autre
mais ça c'est peut-être lui qui l'avait
vu comme ça mais franchement nous l'a
vécue comme une heure peut-être que lui
il était dans cet état là puisque c'est
normal c'est quand même lui qui portait
le film il était en plus cadreur c'est
vraiment un projet qui lui appartient
complètement donc je pense que c'était
plus difficile pour lui que pour nous ça
c'est le plaisir d'être actrice moi je
permettrai pas c'est que on est
interprète on arrive on fait les choses
on n'a pas cette responsabilité de des
fusions de l'université de france soir
c'était savait bien ce côté le cliché de
l'électricité entre des femmes ensemble
dans un vase clos un peu déçu quand oui
ou c'est comme si vous faites un match
de boxe
vous imaginez toujours que les deux
hommes se détestent mais ça fait partie
des du plaisir mais au fond on
finalement n'y avait pas tout ça vous
avez aimé chanter oui je crois que
toutes les actus et m6 ont été tous les
acteurs ont envie de chanter c'est
quelque chose de tellement agréable de
tellement physique de tellement direct
tout le monde était très heureux et tout
est axé choix était très très contente
de interpréter une scène qui est une des
scènes fortes du film d'ailleurs s'est
bien gardé de nous en laisser un extrait
on irait si vous discutez où vous crêper
le chignon avait finalement ça termine
en lacets fiévreusement sur la moquette
avec un baiser torride très beau il est
très pâle et bestial manger des trucs
comme ça
pas évident quand même c'est vrai qu'il
ya 20 ans aurait peut-être fait beaucoup
parler aujourd'hui c'est plus naturel
mais quand même un mois la nasa va faire
parler quand même enfin j'espère je
pense que c'est quand même pas tout à
fait d'autant plus qu'elle part d'une
chose dramatique pour devenir une chose
violente et elle se termine par un effet
de serre est une chose assez sensuelle
et se termine et incluant le sensuel et
se terminer ah bon vous appelez ça
comment sexuel quand même non ça fait
presque
et puis ça se termine en comédie presque
ce que l'arrivée des filles qui
reviennent qui nous découvrent comme ça
donc c'est totalement album de de
préhension ou sur rendez vous celui-ci
met autant dû se battre parce que pour
se battre il faut savoir se bat et moi
j'avais très peur bruit mal à catherine
mais oui parce qu'on n'est pas des
professionnels cascadeuse c'est vrai que
ça c'est une crème qu'on a toujours
donné une gifle à rayons c'est
épouvantable ce nouveau cinéma là pour
vous
expliquer comment arrêter le gel c'est
toujours je trouve une crainte terry
deçà de la peur de deux fermes alors que
dans la vie si ça arrive ça arrive plus
compliqué que je vois un baiser de
gifler ah oui je préfère indécis qu'une
gifle
de toute façon dans la vie je préfère un
baiser cognitif mais je veux faire bonne
et à ben je préfère donner un baiser
franchement tunisie fabrice et c'est
très difficile d'être agressif sur
commande
vous vous connaissiez vous aviez jamais
tourné ensemble jamais on se connaissait
un peu vous n'avez jamais une journée
ensemble
mais moi je ne connaissais aucune des
actrices je n'avais jamais tourné avec
le cube et s'ils n'ont pas fait partie
du plaisir parce que on se voit de loin
et puis tout d'un coup on s'y retrouver
dans ces équations là et moi je me suis
dit j'aurais aimé aller plus loin plus
profondément avec chaque quine mais moi
je pense que j'aurais aimé ses contours
le film en extérieur c'est à dire qu'on
ne soit pas à paris qui veut qu'on
aurait pu se voir le soir qu'on aurait
pu dans le même hôtel et ça c'est le
plaisir se trouvent des tournages quand
on n'est pas à paris à paris tout le
monde retrouve sa vie et et voilà j'en
aurais je reçus un peu plus de choses de
chacune
silic ce que vous nous décrivez vous
étiez avant vous avez tout envie de
devenir amie anne on va devenir vice et
se connaître
j'ai un moment partagé dans une phase où
se connaître mieux vaut d'être plus
voilà que malgré les ravinois je sais
pas comme une équipe de télévision un
tournage ça ne dure que deux mois et
j'ai résultant c'est un début un milieu
et une fin
alors qu'il ya un phénomène de grandes
vacances on veut en profiter parce qu'on
sait qu'on se retrouvera pas c'est pas
le phénomène du bureau tous les jours on
va voir les mêmes têtes
donc il y avait une sorte de joie
éphémère dont on a bien profité et d'un
mot quand vous avez vu le film monté
première projection vous avez retrouvé
ce que vous aviez vécu non c'était autre
chose j'ai une certaine surprise et il y
avait plus de drôlerie que je ne l'avais
vécu plus d'insolite aussi vous savez
quand on tourne pendant deux mois tous
les jours dans un décor unique
il ya forcément des moments et disons un
petit peu plus difficile donc je n'avais
pas je connaissais le scénario mais je
n'avais pas vécu exactement ce que j'ai
retrouvé sur l'écran puis heureusement
parce que d'abord il y avait un travail
de montage formidable et il ne reste que
ce qui devait être dans le film mais
c'est la quintessence des gens de ce
qu'on a fait est qu'ils restent dans le
film et c'est ça ce que j'aime
d'ailleurs au cinéma moi ce qui me
frappe c'est toujours la décalage
emprunt un scénario et après chaque rôle
interprété par justement catherine
emmanuel isabelle je trouve qu'il ya une
histoire et puis après ils me faxer
incarné sur l'écran ça appartient
exactement à celles qui ont incarné oui
un film ça se déplace beaucoup entre le
moment où on a lu le scénario en tournée
le moment où marisa se déplacent
énormément et heureusement d'ailleurs
merci beaucoup des invitations huit
femmes de françois ozon sortie demain
sur les écrans